a new 13 reasons why theory has emerged
about Hanna Baker and to be completely
honest with you it's pretty believable
spoiler alert this video contains
spoilers of the first and second season
don't forget to hit that notification
valve to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
Hanna Baker's final reason why 13
reasons why is a controversial show
that's loosely based on a same-named
book the series touches on some of the
most non discussed topics teenagers have
to deal with in their everyday life it's
been wildly praised for its ability to
talk about some of the most tough topics
which were introduced to people who need
to hear about them the most it opened a
lot of communication doors and caused
plenty of controversial moments in the
first season we slowly get to learn
about Hanna Baker and her classmates who
according to Hanna are each a reason why
she decided to take her own life
but despite the stated reasons some fans
seem to think there's a lot more to this
show the second season opened even more
stories about what Hanna went through
before she took her life and the fans of
the show quickly became alert to one
theory there seem to be a bunch of clues
that are pointing out to the fact that
Hanna might have been pregnant before
her passing and although this theory is
still very fresh and brief it's quickly
spreading on the Internet
it states that Bryce Walker actually
impregnated Hanna during his horrible
act there's no way you'd be able to know
this from the first season but the
second season actually showed several
extremely hidden clues that all seem to
be pointing in the same direction
friendship with Tony Padilla the theory
talks about the unexplainable friendship
with Tony if you remember Tony seems to
be always around whenever it's
convenient for him and he really seems
to know everything that's going on Hanan
was pretty trusting when it came to Tony
even though it's never even revealed how
the two met the second season mentions
that Hanna has a big secret and Tony
knows about it but that's just about
everything it says so what if this huge
secret actually is the
that Hannah was pregnant for the Brice's
unwanted child Express UK states that
this would also confirm why Tony would
get so close to Hannah's mom and comfort
her so much after her passing even
though we really don't get an
explanation as to why they're so close
in the first place
final episode the final episode also had
several clues as to why pregnancy might
actually be a possible secret Han has
been holding from everyone when Miss
Baker hands over the 11 reasons why not
we see that Hannah mentions she might be
able to make a difference in someone
else's life someday but she could be
talking about her story she could also
be talking about the fact that this
someone else could be her kid we also
know that Bryce didn't really use
protection during his acts with any of
the girls which he admitted to in his
testimony seriously he's one of the most
horrible characters in TV history and
since we all know Bryce's ugly past the
statement also foreshadowed the fact
that his girlfriend Chloe could possibly
be pregnant also but this could also be
a big hint at Hannah's pregnancy and yet
another reason why she felt like she
could no longer carry on it's something
that unfortunately happens more than
people might think and considering the
show touched on so many horrible topics
we have a feeling they did want to also
talk about teen pregnancy we can't even
imagine what Hanna must have been
feeling but we are wondering if we'll
ever know the truth thirteen reasons why
isn't going anywhere and who knows what
will happen
season 3 has now officially been
confirmed unfortunately it doesn't seem
like the second season has been so well
received as the first Rotten Tomatoes
gave it a surprising 50 percent low
score while the previous season
maintains a high score of 80 percent
that's quite a difference isn't it and
it's not just critics many fans seem to
have really mixed feelings about the
show that was once one of the most
talked about Netflix shows ever
while this theory would definitely add
another layer to Hannah's story and talk
about an extremely common topic that
definitely needs more attention some of
the fans were really let down by the
second season and how everything played
out it's even more interesting since
Hannah
aka Katherine Lankford hasn't been
confirmed to return for the third season
which could mean that the pregnancy
story will shift to Chloe or won't exist
at all
fans have definitely had a mixed
reaction with many wondering if another
season will really be necessary of
course in through Twitter style people
have shared many jokes to show how they
feel about their team reasons why after
the second season since the book pretty
much finished with the first season it
means that the directors have now the
freedom to create their own stories
which we have clearly seen from the
second however this might also mean that
the stories might move too far away from
the original and lose the reason why so
many people tuned in to watch the show
to begin with although we have a feeling
13 reasons why we'll definitely win
people back with this next season we
just have to be patient the real
question is wouldn't you think about
this theory and 13 reasons why in
general do you like the show hate it let
us know in the comments we would love to
talk with you and hear your opinions and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]